REPUBLICANS WHO READ IT SAY IT
SUGGESTS SERIOUS SURVEILLANCE
ABUSES BY TOP OFFICIALS AT THE
FBI AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE TO
APPROVE THE RELEASE.
LET'S BRING IN A MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
STARTING WITH YOU, CONGRESSMAN
GATES.
I TALKED TO ONE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES EARLIER AND HE SAID
BE CAREFUL IN THE HYPING THE
CONTENT OF THIS MEMO.
HE SAID, I THINK SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE OVER SELLING
WHAT'S IN IT.
THIS IS NOT THE SMOKING GUN
THAT'S GOING STOP THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK THEY'RE BUILDING UP
PEOPLE'S EXPECTATIONS TO A
RIDICULOUSLY HIGH EXTENT.
I HEARD THAT AND THIS IS SOMEONE
I REALLY RESPECT AND IT MADE ME
NERVOUS.
CONGRESSMAN.
ALL THE OTHER STUNNING
INFORMATION WE LEARN FROM ANDREW
McCABE'S MESSAGE ON A PRO-HILARY
STRZOK AND I THINK YES THE MEMO
IN AND OF ITSELF, DOESN'T THE
FULL FOREEE.
THE MULE
THE MUL
THE MUEL
THE MUELLE
THE MUELLER PROBE
THE MUELLER PROBE I
THE MUELLER PROBE IS ROT
THE MUELLER PROBE IS ROTTE
THE MUELLER PROBE IS ROTTEN
THE MUELLER PROBE IS ROTTEN T
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TRIED TO PUSH OFF THE DOSSIER TO
THE SIDE AND IT LOOKS LIKE IT
WAS USED MULTIPLE TIMES TO
JUSTIFY IF HE SURVEILLANCE.
WHAT'S THE PUBLIC NEED TO
UNDERSTAND.
PEOPLE HEAR DOSSIER AND THINK
IT'S TOO MUCH FOR ME TO
COMPREHEND.
WHAT ON A FRIDAY NIGHT CAN WE
TELL THE VIEWING PUBLIC WHY THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE IS SO
IMPORTANT.
>> IT HAS BEEN REPORTED IT WAS
USED AND HOPEFULLY THIS MEMO
WILL CONFIRM WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S TRUE.
HERE'S WHY THIS MATTERS, IF
THAT'S INDEED IN THE MEMO,
LAURA, THAT OF ITSELF IS A
MODERN-DAY POLITICAL SCANDAL
THAT'S NEARLY UNRIVAL.
YOU'RE SAYING THERE WAS A
CAMPAIGN DOCUMENT PAID FOR AND
PRODUCED BY ONE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN AND THE FBI UFT
CAMPAIGN AND THE FBI USED I
CAMPAIGN AND THE FBI USED IT
CAMPAIGN AND THE FBI USED IT F
CAMPAIGN AND THE FBI USED IT FOR
JUSTIFYING SPY ONG A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
THIS IN ITSELF IS A TERRIFYING
THE GOAL POST IN THIS AS WHAT
COUNTS AS SHOCKING OR
SCANDALOUS.
IT NEEDS TO BE VIEWED BAD IN IT
OF ITSELF IF THAT'S THE CASE.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK WITH THE
MORALE OF THE FBI.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE USUALLY BIG
CRITIC OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE RELENTLESS SCRUTINY WILL
DAMAGE RETENTION AND SHAKE THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST.
YOUR VIEW ON THAT?
>> THOSE THINGS ARE STATED TO
FURTHER THEIR OWN CAUSE.
THE FINE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
FBI WILL GO ON DOING THEIR JOB
DAY AFTER DAY IN A SUPERIOR
MANNER.
THEIR BADGES ARE NOT TARNISHED
BY THE ACTIONS OF SOMEBODY ELSE.
THEIR BADGES ARE AS SHINY AS
EVER.
THE ONLY TARNISHED BADGERS ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO PERFORMED IN A
HORRIBLE MANNER IF THAT'S
PROVABLE.
THE PREDICATION FOR THE FISA
WARRANT IS ATROCIOUS.
IT PUTS IN JEOPARDY FUTURE FISA
WARRANTS GOING BEFORE FISA
JUDGES IN COURT.
>> Laura: IT MAKES IT SEEM
STARTING THE FBI FOR A POLITICAL
THEY DID THERE.
THEY CALL PRESIDENT TRUMP A
DICTATOR.
I FIND THIS CLOSER TO
POLICE-STATE TACTICS THAN
ANYTHING THEY'VE ACCUSED HIM OF
AND CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO GO
BACK TO YOU ON THIS.
THE FACT WE STILL HAVE AGENTS
WORKING AND INVESTIGATORS,
LAWYERS WORK IN THIS
INVESTIGATION WITH SUCH CLEAR --
AT LEAST THE APPEARANCE OF A
THE PRESIDENT IS STUNNING
WHETHER IT'S ANDREW WEISSMANN OR
ANY OF THESE OTHER PEOPLE,
THEY'RE STILL IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
ABOUT THE INTELLIGENCE MEMO IS
NAMES ARE NAMED.
WE'LL SEE WHO IS ENGAGED IN
CONDUCT THAT'S SHOCKED ME AND SO
MANY IN CONGRESS.
THE RESULT IN THIS SHOULD BE
BIPARTISAN LEGISLATION TO
STICKING AROUND AFTER BAD ACTS.
HAVE YOU MORE OVERSIGHT, MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND THEN WE CAN
RESTORE CONFIDENCE IN THE FBI
AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE DON'T ENJOY BEATING UP ON THE
ENTITIES ESSENTIAL TO PRESERVE
>> Laura: AND KIMBERLY, THE MOVE
TO FOCUS ON WHETHER TRUMP WAS
ITCHING TO FIRE MULLER OR SAID
SOMETHING AND WHETHER HE WAS
IT'S UNCLEAR.
THE PRESIDENT'S BACK FROM
SWITZERLAND NOW.
TO ME THAT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
THE INVESTIGATORS WERE WORK ON
IT WERE BIASSED OR CLINTON OR
>> THERE'S NO CRIME IN ASKING
QUESTIONS TOO.
IN THE CONFIDENCE OF YOUR INNER
CIRCLE, RAISING QUESTIONS ON
WHETHER OR NOT THERE ARE
CONFLICTS OR BIAS AND WHETHER OR
NOT THAT IS A CAUSE FOR ANY SORT
OF ACTION.
SO NOW WE SPENT TWO DAYS TALKING
ABOUT A THOUGHT THAT WENT
THROUGH PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HEAD.
WE KEEP HEARING FROM CRITICS OF
THE PRESIDENT THAT THE RIGHT OR
CONSERVATIVES ENGAGE IN
DIVERSIONARY TACTICS THERE
SHOULD BE SELF-REFLECTION.
THE DISCUSSION AT THE MOMENT IS
WHAT HAPPENED AT 2016 IN TERMS
OF THE FBI.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION